so on campus besides our language
classes our students have some
opportunities to interact with native
Japanese speakers also we have lots of
events one major event is lunch table
that is actually sponsored by MIT Japan
which actually is a program that sends a
lot of our students to Japan as
internship so together was MIT Japan
program and we host a Japanese lunch
table once a week so that student go to
lunch table and then native speakers of
Japanese especially the Japanese Wives
Club at MIT they really support this
activity we also have Japan at MIT event
this spend this event is also in
collaboration with MIT Japan and at the
beginning of each semester we kind of
you know have a big party together with
Cissie and then we introduce a language
program at the same time we introduce a
lot of Japan related culture courses and
then we invite like Japanese vibes clubs
so that a student can be exposed to like
cultural activities such as tea ceremony
or how to wear kimono those kind of
things